cinnamon toast King design what's at
least it's time to review another ready
my god I don't know if I'm ready
I really cannot really cuz merica just
came in I'm sorry hang on what can
professionally
it's time for another video this time
we're reviewing creepy asteroids oh my
god
Felix what a creepy asterisk exactly
what it says hey can hey where's the
exit take them away
I'm really bad at this Jesus Christ
okay nice record bro hey comfortable
okay let's freakin do this
that's what creepy aster exists it's
when you roleplay with people online by
using asterisks let's see how other
people engage with asterisks wrong
number texted a meme last night thought
it belonged here hi
hey who's this clears throat it's
Brandon from class sweating profusely I
think you got the wrong number
haha looks down at the ground to our
league thumbs Shannon gave me your
number that's cool but you have the
wrong number
I'm a 25 year old man come on it's
Brandon from econ I asked Shannon for
your number let's hang out winky face
hand itching to unzip pants what the
hell is it jumping right to it oh jeez
Brandon goes he jumps into it literally
he just gets right in there trigger
finger pulls it straight out so this is
what creepy answers dude okay now I see
it is creepy Brandon you have the wrong
number I'm not a woman I literally have
a mustache Hey look as you can what oh
oh this got out every time I want to
unzip
pants as good this itchy hey-oh but to
unleash my power my friend got some
weird text from a guy she knows and she
decided to fight fire with fire
kisses your supple bare breasts and
areolas runs fingers through hair takes
mine I can solve off your dick then
fortunately watch you choke to death on
your own genitals then to suppose your
body in a heavily wooded area WTF how
could you do that to me
oh my god I was kissing your breasts
great that'll be the monetize great oh
god I don't think we need to read this
one of course oh gosh a post yesterday
inspired me to try this out on my
girlfriend Julie looks desaad shyly hey
hey there honey
puts hands on your hips how was your day
Beth where's that look shocked and sad
oh you don't want you don't want to tell
me puts hands in pockets
dejectedly mmm baby don't turn into
referring oh it's fairies doing this
oh no he says goddamn fairies last
Friday no makes your feet and giggles as
you squirm is that the noise you make
for the wink III face okay what the
actual fudge are you serious with this
role-playing crap are you just meaning
it art are you not into it
whines and hides head thinking about how
such a screw-up
and how nobody likes me begins to cry
are you pooping me I am pooping you know
don't poop me I want them to continue I
want like a proper horrible exchange do
you want to date me no fine I'll wait a
hundred years if I have to I'll be dead
by then
okay price open your casket
too bad lifts you out carefully from the
mahogany burial box you need a shower
[Music]
you need some milk to keep those bones
unbuckles you need some man milk rips
shirt open shows masculinity dominance
looks shot - gasps gets little gets a
little excited
as you up and down gets angry but then
realize I like it too hand is itching to
wipe sweat off brow
how are you unzip your pants who is this
you don't remember me where's Webster
wait tears
it's me from class okay I still know you
but hi would you like to go on and which
old date with me stains taller nope why
not you're missing out in my meat and my
meat oh we're doing this now hold on
boyfriend walks in the room Ponder's
shipping our pants
no it won't be intimidated by you pulls
out bulging me sector this big as it
gets and when it when equipped precious
hip statistic o meets after that's one
way to segue into a dick pic Jesus is
like they just can't wait to get to dick
out like how they had an anime moment of
confrontation no no I will not back down
I must continue
mew mew kind of you for no reason
go yourself ah also sad looks shocked
and dejected but my itchy super hand
can't happy stop pull out some meat
scepter that's because I also have mine
on giggles I kiss you passionately
ooh I'm really sorry but I'm really not
into asterisks oh okay I'm sorry
I'll stop hose out meet scepter how
about this hey blushes nervously who is
this eyebrows furrow in sadness you read
my message and didn't reply I expected
better from you
ice water and I pick him it's okay
[Music]
I also also know that you are why is
that always the case as I've ever know
you sniffles through tears
it's me from homeroom I wanted to why
did they do this stuttering every why
don't you go and teach sometime have a
boyfriend dude you know this thing be
like that my ice my ice Club blue like
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is this brother I was so confused
what are you doing
Oh God Oh God
[Laughter]
um sure I guess
crawls in bed with you hi there hello
smiley
did he use cringy Asterix often you owe
me to stop using them it's just a little
weird okay I'll stop touches your
breasts understandable have nice days it
just goes from like zero to 100 every
time it's like oh hey how you doing
gropes you what's the UH explain to me
the Sasuke meme why is everybody on
Twitter choking out Sasuke Leila I don't
know no one likes Sasuke I guess I'll
get it it's like there's him and someone
like with their hand off the screen like
they're choking it was like it just
looks funny I don't know what a furry
[ __ ] Jesus Christ talk what do you mean
by furry talk
it is a furry thing no are you serious
my thing are there's always room on big
Papa's lap fat allow me to save this
conversation you silly troubling what do
you think of the rapidly inflating
economy of resume Bob that kids save it
crisis averted
I remember you could do Asterix would
like its beauty bots still alive I think
it I got it still it still lie ok let me
do let's do a straight oh no I feel
about one another proper watching you
Robert Asterix with yourself to embers
like they're under I'll do anything run
say for you to come please no more
35 now yeah it kicked I surrender we
salute land ice are under shelter
surrender flag and coughed out blood
[Music]
wait how old are you
Oh unbuckles bra takes off your shirt
his palms are sweaty
Nix your belly belly
let me see its beauty there's mom is on
your you're okay
mom spaghetti konnichiwa notice that
you're a boy dish you has a girlfriend
ooh giggles my books jiggling what
you're back what why do you got jiggly
books okay can time for outro my
favorite part of the video where we
welcome to say what ken that's so weird
[Music]
[Laughter]
you want pyramids we got oh oh you're
into castles huh we got you covered baby
you want some bets easy
we got it all this game is still
relevant goddammit